[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys what's going on
chat it's cold man it's cold I don't
know why but today I've been a lot more
cold than I normally am can you hear me
Dart
yes I can hear you fine sir
I have no idea why it's always like this
it's like literally at the beginning
with this new system I can barely I
can't hear them for a couple of seconds
oh there we go now I can hear you
here it's always the same way I I can't
hear you for a couple seconds and then
bam I can start hearing you
it's it's stupid but what's going on
guys this is uh yo we're back here at
another
another attic show talk about the past
present future gaming you know I'm
setting up uh stuff a little bit we got
a little bit different of a show for you
guys today I'm gonna switch it up a
little bit not much but a little bit
uh so dirt and what's been going on man
what's up bro how you doing
pretty good
I don't know why but like I'm tired
really
well it happens you know it happens
so what you've been playing man what's
been going on with you
well I've been playing
um I see Hi-Fi rush I'm on the last boss
actually so I'll probably finish that
later tonight it's not easy the last
couple of bosses in that game is not
easy by the way
all right it's definitely a little
challenge there the the check with the
wings is was a little oh yeah
yeah I actually
uh the the one before the one with the
wings it kind of that they give you the
most issues like because it wasn't a
traditional fight
yeah yeah
I agree uh but yeah so I'm on the final
boss um I'm assuming you finish this
issue that that like deep into the game
yeah I already beat it I beat it
um
Saturday okay one second okay yeah
that's cool so yeah I'm on the final
boss and I also been playing a little
yeah
I'm gonna talk about it uh you know
actually let's go straight into that man
let's go straight into that
hi
Rush thoughts
uh you know look at that yeah get a
little bit more advanced here a little
bit
[Applause]
so as you can see let me make sure that
the gameplay isn't playing too loud I'm
gonna keep it up just a little bit you
know I I do like the uh the aesthetic of
this obviously it could look a little
bit cleaner uh I will admit to you guys
but I do I did beat this guy beat it
fully and I want to just go over you
know little things that we played on it
what exactly did you enjoy it yo
I want to
give your overall impression someone
said take care of that copyright music
you're right I'm just going to mute the
whole stream
think about that I even think about that
uh so what's going on man what what is
your thoughts on high five Rush
listen I want to tell you um
somebody called me out like like
yesterday for say oh you
you kept all Xbox games and that's just
not true it's just not true
if I like a game I like a game if I
don't I don't
um so I'm sitting there to say this
Hi-Fi Rush is an absolute blast I'm not
just saying that because I'm team Xbox
it is a blast
I saw somebody say on Twitter it kind of
reminds me of a PS2 original Xbox
Dreamcast style of game and bro as
someone who's older that was in his 20s
during those days in his early 20s
that definitely what it reminds me of
the music is awesome the gameplay is
awesome
little story uh but the graphics is
something that really impressed me
because I told the story uh attic um
when we heard that Tango game works it's
quote unquote doing a passing project it
was uh
you know what does that mean but I would
say I am pleasantly surprised with high
fry Rush it's a it's a great game like
you said you finished it I'm on the
final boss
and I actually stopped playing dead
space remake to 100 focus on this game
to finish it and it's an awesome game
man it's just you know it's a breath of
fresh air
to be honest with you now look
Dead Space remake amazing experience uh
you know I hope everyone I I hope
everyone enjoys that space remake uh but
at the same time it's like look you know
this is a new experience and I would
recommend someone trying something like
this out I get it
it's not
the most ideal thing you know
um
I feel like they had to promote this as
a a rhythm game but part of me wishes
they would have really vocalize like the
amount of
stuff that you don't really have to do
in terms of a rhythm game you know I
agree yeah man my computers are going
crazy right now everything good though
everything good
so I I think that's my biggest thing
it's like you know is this a rhythm game
yes uh but I don't feel like
I don't feel like they really
capitalize and explain it's a rhythm
game but you could play this exactly how
you want to they can you you don't it
kind of it rewards you for having a
rhythm it doesn't it doesn't punish you
and I think that needs to really be
front center in the marketing yep
I think you put that perfectly it
rewards you but it doesn't punish you
absolutely
yeah so someone said they said that in
the presentation that they did but you
know how it is a lot of these places
when it comes to stuff like this they'll
they'll say something like that but if
you actually like play the game they
don't mean it you know what I'm saying
like right they'll be like okay you know
this is randomly like but is it really
do you really need uh can you really
play it without a rhythm and a lot of
these games they they they sell you a
dream uh because that's all they care
about you play in the game they don't
care if it's good if it's bad you know
I'm gonna say we started this at seven
minutes I I'm I'm bugging man I'm
bugging time timestamp Mafia I apologize
you know
if you want to sit if you want to send
the crew it's okay I got time I got time
today it's cold man I'ma hear you walk
through the door because you ain't gonna
be able to walk anywhere without
shivering
Yeah man they gonna be on your head man
you may get them time stamps correct sir
but
I do enjoy this game now let me ask you
a question let's not spoil anything
uh how did you feel about
about the the mission before the last
boss where it's like stuff was going
crazy
you know there there's that big thing in
the middle I'm sure you know what I'm
talking about like I felt like that was
the height of this game oh yeah that was
fire bro that was absolute fire you know
like okay not to spoil anything but
there's a part where you fight something
it's pretty big right uh and that was
just absolute fire man that goes to show
you that this game is polished it's
polished it's a I would probably say
it's a high quality double A and the
only reason I say double A because my
boy sean76 said the price is only thirty
dollars so I said okay
technically that's a double a game price
but damn
my boy found him crack and that's in the
chat he he said he's calling it a triple
A because it's just that polish and and
some of the boss fights are super
creative
yeah this this game surprised the hell
out of me
after Xbox 2022 not having any first
party games and stuff like AAA first
fighting games even though this
technically isn't a AAA
damn it's high quality bro yeah and
that's where I always get like the
confusion on what a triple A what a
double a what a single a
it can get very confusing on what is
what and I think this is a prime example
of a game that is a double A that I
would say but
if they would have had like Sunset
Overdrive money could have easily been a
very successful AAA game easily easily
and I think that they did very well with
what they had can you shut the door
please shame change he said this is a
triple eight but he got two A's
capitalized and the last eight a small
small case so yeah I like that changing
I agree with that I like that
yeah so you know what's crazy I'm
looking at the the chat uh why is people
showing up in different colors all of a
sudden like red light blue is that like
what their profile is like I don't I
don't know what's going on there is that
happening over there on your stuff uh
I'm seeing a lot of colors
um why so serious Wade Johnson I don't
know I don't know why their no their
names are different colors now oh that's
not on my end no that's on your end for
whatever reason oh their names aren't
different colors in Miami yeah on my end
they got people with their names red
blue
oh no no
oh I did you know I did just see
somebody uh drinking ninja his green
yeah I'm a drunken ninjas is great
because he's a member of the oh okay
okay his makes sense
uh but the chain uh maybe it's maybe
they're doing an update on the back end
yeah and they're trying to figure some
stuff out because we lit I hear you man
I hear you
I I I think that
high five Rush is so far one of the
better games I've played uh this year
it's not so much over here so obviously
that's pretty easy but what I will say
is I think this is the best game
Microsoft's made in years
that's come out of their camp
yeah
listen my personal opinion on the matter
I can't disagree with you bro it's it's
just that quality is it is just that
polished it's it's a really good game
it's a really good game
and I think it's so good that even
though there are some people trying to
hate on it you know so it's cartoony
they was talking that trash but they
quickly shut up
when they saw the success the review
scores
and how digital Foundry said is one of
the best looking games they've seen
so a lot of those guys shut their traps
but at the end of the day I agree with
you this is one of the best Xbox
exclusives in a while
um I mean like besides you know the
Force of Horizon games obviously but you
know that's you know that's racing games
but yeah I I agree with you it's a
quality game bro and to me it's just
like why
why don't people want these games to
succeed like the the like the cultivar
thing is just be crazy sometimes like
because these are good that means future
games are going to do good if if these
do extremely well that means other
people are going to you know bite they
style a little bit make better games I
see someone said I need an evil within
three uh but keep in mind I don't know
if they'll make an evil within three but
the person that's actually developing
the game he didn't make this like the
the head of the studio right right
because he was there with another
individual and he's the the studio lead
on this game John Johannes yeah so
Georgia Hondas actually made this game
but let me ask you this start seeing the
high quality of Hi-Fi Rush
you know I wasn't the biggest fan of
pentiment I wasn't the biggest fan I
couldn't get into it I've grounded to a
point I think it's a lot better game uh
than a lot of people give credit for but
I was very against the making pandemic
because I was like there's a lot of
other stuff that you guys could have
done you know what I'm saying yeah but
after seeing this
I do think that I've come around on that
right it's like
they could easily do stuff and have a
really good success rate with it
oh yeah I agree um
I played pantomime for like 30 minutes I
couldn't get into it but I will give it
another shot
I'm okay with games like pentiment and
grounded as long as they're still
developing games like a vowed and out of
Wars too
I'm definitely fine with games like
Hi-Fi rush and it's even better because
they're making games like this a high
quality
double a
um borderline AAA but at the same time
they're still going to do some Triple A
titles I love that
um I think that's important because that
mean that we're going to still be
getting constant content I mean
consistent content
um and you know every game listen bro I
am a 46 year old man right
I say my age for a reason some people
want to say I've been a 50. I'm in my
50s but I'm not I will not lie about my
age
I've been playing games for a long time
and when games there were games back in
the 90s I would play that would be 30
minutes long bro finish them oh that
game was amazing absolutely amazing so
now we have these huge AAA games which I
love them but at the same time
every game doesn't have to be a huge AAA
game a game like tunic I love that game
a game like uh [__] what's the game with
the black crow
death's door love that game you know
there's so many games that
we can play and a game like Hi-Fi Rush
man was perfect absolutely perfect the
perfect timing the perfect situation
shallow dropped absolutely love it and
it's and it's sitting at a 90 metacrity
right now are you cold at it now
got it cold y'all yeah you know it I
don't know why but like maybe I'm
starting to catch something but like
geez I'm freezing oh man that's why like
in my basement is always cold that's why
I'm always wearing hoodies and thick uh
I have a Naruto hoodie I've looked for
briefly you know today just not been a
good day for me in general
uh but I I'm starting to come around you
know I think see the problem is is this
bed's leaning against the heater because
you might might have my apartment is
built underground a little bit like I
have a window
but it's literally almost at the ground
floor wow so like to about my kneecap is
is underground yeah I got you I could I
compared to that I've seen apartments
with the yeah like the first floor is
kind of underground yeah yeah so pretty
much what's happened is
the
the uh what's what I'm looking for
the heat is trapped in this apartment to
a lot of degree it rare it will be like
the only time I've turned the heat on
is when we had the huge cold wave that
was like below 15 20 degrees Yeah that's
the only time I ever really turn it on
it is during stuff like that uh you know
most the time it stays relatively warm
in here uh that's why my bed's against
the heater you know what I'm saying uh
but you know after the podcast you know
I think that bed's getting scooted out a
little bit and I think I'm about to turn
that heater on I know yeah man you might
have got them five dollars super angry
therapist MD High far Rush was a great
game it was uh and it wasn't 70 yeah
definitely this game would have been
obliterated if it was 70 dollars uh I'm
glad that they chose not to do that and
I'm be honest man um I'm not a PC guy
but when you saw like the the user
reviews on on Steam listen man you can
save you one of my PC guys I'm not a PC
guy at all but they will be honest if
they don't like a game they will tell
you they don't like a game
and that game had a lot of positive
review scores
and that could that is going to show you
that is a damn good game man as like
people try to hate on it but I think
this is one of them types of games where
they can hate on it as much as they can
but at the end of the day
you really can't hate on it if you
understand what I'm saying you know you
can you know like I said like I said a
90 Metacritic a selling well it was some
top five on Steam and and it was a
shadow drop
um you know so I think that's the type
of game man you really you know you
could try your best to hate on the but
in reality you really can't unless you
just you know
it was like yeah
so Shadow drop and it was killing it's
killing it man it's still a Hot Topic
right now and it's been a week
so yeah someone said are you still going
to Planet Fitness I didn't go yesterday
or today I'm probably gonna go tomorrow
I'm too
I'm definitely not trying to go in that
cold gym right now definitely not trying
to do that but you know I I think hi if
I Rush they showed me that it's like
look you know you might not like all of
the passion projects that some of these
companies do but you know there's a lot
of perks to these passion projects one
it gives the studio creative Outlet to
keep some of the the vets and the
seniority and you know a lot of the
talent there at the studio because
they're able to like you know they're
able to stretch that
that um
that creative memory that creative
muscle
and when you're able to do that you're a
little bit more happier in this scenario
um you know I honestly yeah and then you
you could keep more people because
people feel like they have options yeah
it's always nice to have options and
like look I didn't like I didn't like
pinned him it wasn't really my type of
game but I loved high five rush so you
know giving you're giving you get man
you know not every one of these games is
going to appeal to everyone but I can
guarantee you the the studios that you
know obsidian I might not have liked
grounded I think it was a decent game
but I'm sure there's a lot of people
that wouldn't even tried grounded
but they like Hi-Fi rush like me and
there's some people that didn't like
Hi-Fi rush they were like grounded and
then there's some people that don't like
either one of those but they like pinned
it Dependable right yeah so I think the
I think the studio thing is is a win you
know keep doing that my question to you
dirt and you know tell me if I'm wrong
do you think that
when it comes to
that's what I'm looking for
a studio that has multiple teams do you
think there is a number
where at that point
you're spreading the numbers of the
actual Studio too thin
of how many teams is there
um
for a second I thought
obsidian would spread themselves too
thin
um because what they have like 250
developers or something around there and
they had like
five different games in development at
the same time but I guess it's like I'm
gonna look at it like this
if they're able to handle it if the
games they're releasing a quality like
obsidian
I don't really you know like Phantom is
really not my Boogie but it's you know
it reviews solid same thing with
grounded
all the worlds
I'm assuming in the future hopefully
about reviews grade and also out of
Worlds too so if they're able to pull it
off
I say go for it you know if they're able
to do it just like even with um
I remember like Ninja Theory
when like before they were bought by
Microsoft they already had a small
Studio like 75 people at the time like
of course they're much bigger now but
they were just doing games and had 10
people doing this game 20 people did
hair blade so more people did some other
stuff and that's what they had to do in
order to get as many projects going you
know to feed their families so if they
can get away with it if if the games are
still quality not if they're not if it's
like Platinum
and they're doing so many projects it's
hurting other games that's one thing but
if they're able to maintain
I'm all for it bro
I agree with you as long as they're able
to successfully complete the games I
think me I would prefer
your primary team that makes you know uh
the foundation of your Studios like for
instance obsidian I would say their
foundations RPGs you got the primary
Studio making that that game which would
be the vow currently right and then you
have the secondary Studio making
something unique or making a smaller
project or they split the studio in
literally half and have one team working
on a big project and the other teamwork
on a big project yeah uh so you know I
think obsidian has earned the right to
have that freedom because if you think
about it they're making the outer worlds
they're making a vowed they just got
that uh they just got the pinnamon out
so they they're they're pretty stretched
too and Ninja Theory they're working on
like two or three games yep
yep I think double fine well I know
they're working on two or three games
but in the past they have you know
um but now they're on the Microsoft so
I'm I'm expecting them to have an
announcement probably next year
hopefully because uh secondary two came
out of 2021 so hopefully they'll have an
announcement soon for their next game
and I think that's where I stand right
now it's like I would prefer
two teams on working on two big games
I'm sure you can have a big team working
on a big game and two teams working on
smaller games but I think like logistic
wise it makes more sense for Game Pass
to constantly have in these you know
crazy experiences going into game pass
but you know you need the smaller titles
and I feel like you have plenty of
Studios that can handle those smaller
titles like every Studio that Microsoft
currently owns don't expect to AAA
product from you know double fine huh
no not I agree absolutely yeah I think
double fines gonna make high quality
double A games I think compulsion to a
point is going to make that mixture
between double A and Triple A I think
hellblade you'll get probably a triple
you'll get Triple A in terms of like
hellblade uh but I don't think I don't
think Ninja Theory is going to be on you
like multiple I think that'll be one of
the studios that like look you're gonna
work on Hellboy 2 and then maybe a
smaller title
I can see that what do you think project
Mars going to be you think it's going to
be a smaller title
I don't know the the way things are
going and as long as it's coming I
wouldn't be surprised if they convert
that to a VR title oh really I doubt it
it could not happen but it's just been a
minute we've never we haven't heard
anything about that game you know I
think they announced it was it 2019
I think yeah it was before Kobe yeah
2019. yeah that was damn I just thought
about that because it was definitely
before covet
wow so I think
I think right now say you said but Xbox
don't got a VR yeah but they they
they're on PC too you know that there's
a lot of PC stuff on there
I don't know what they're doing you know
that's probably speaking really out of
time because it definitely could not
happen but to me when I when I saw the
way that they were promoting that game
it kind of felt like something that
would belong in VR
yeah possibly but like you said that was
a 2019 VR hasn't really exploded so
maybe not you know I don't know maybe
not yeah Nine Lives good point you know
I was going to bring that up a lot of
people are sleeping on exile gaming of
the people that make Wasteland uh I
think you're going to see
Bethesda and you're going to see
obsidian quality RPGs from them
absolutely and let me say something I
remember I was talking to Tim Dogg and
Tim Dog was saying he heard that uh
compulsion
yes before they made smaller games but
now they want to be a AAA team also now
Tim told us this a couple years ago he
said he heard they wanted to be a triple
A team man and the game they're making
is supposed to be
like you mentioned maybe a high quality
double A but he said he think that it's
going to be a triple layer you know with
Microsoft behind them and they got some
people so I I don't know you know like
maybe you know more than me yeah it's
it's it's a
there's some truth behind that there's
some trouble all right so let's let's
move on man we got 32 minutes and we
talking about
EA canceling a single player game that's
tooken place in the TitanFall universe
have you heard about this I read it
right before the show bro
I'm so disappointed with them on that I
I feel like us like they've built all
these characters up from Apex they'd be
stupid not to make a game
that has like one or two of them in it
yeah have you plays a main character one
of them you know it could be third
person because they've shown they can do
both yeah and it just I think it'll be
cool to like
put those together you can even make a
game
that's just how the how the arena
started you know what I'm saying like
how all that started or you could do a
lot of things with that game and it's
just disappointing like you you get all
this positive feedback from EA and you
think they're in the right direction and
then they just
they just throw it off nope we're not
we're not in the right direction we're
we're actually in the wrong direction
but we're gonna we're gonna keep going
man I you know this I think there's
probably a reason that they canceled
this I don't think it was anything
like serious or bad towards the actual
uh respawn and it was probably like just
like look like we you guys are working
on too much stuff you know maybe
we need to pull back on that uh I'm just
at this point it's just like I think
that a Titanfall single player game
would have did very well and I'm very
disappointed in EA for not at least
letting us get one
single player game from the TitanFall
Universe yeah yeah it's unfortunate uh
but like you said we just don't know the
reason they pulled it the reason they
canceled it nowadays maybe there's so
many games that was canceled that we
don't know about
I believe this is just how it is
nowadays was it
um like you said like where they win
themselves too thin they had too many
games in development was the game too
much of a gamble because uh Titanfall 2
didn't do well with a single player
Titanfall not do well so I think all of
those things kind of came into play
and uh you know obviously we don't know
exactly what happened but I can see any
of those things being a reason
you know budget would a budget be too
much for Titanfall game would it be too
much where they you know like was it too
ambitious and uh they didn't want to you
know do it because of the budget so I
don't know man um I'm thinking there's
going to be
unfortunately adding I hate to say it
man there's going to be less
huge AAA big budget uh single player
games in the future unless it's
something you know you can bet on like a
Spider-Man like Star Wars or Hogwarts so
I mean there's going to be some but
the further this generation goes there's
gonna be less of them I hate to say that
but I believe that yeah and I don't
think people realize that you know
in the grand scheme of things
people don't play these single player
games like people think like people
think that there's millions that just go
straight to these type of games not
really you know PlayStation makes the
better ones and they have a few that do
really well but even PlayStation don't
hit all these out of the park you know
you saw uh days gone you know there is
games that they make Horizon to some
degree because I know it kind of dropped
off really fast and these type of games
are very risky to make and the funny
thing is I remember when people was
complaining about what Phil Spencer said
about them he they're trying to act like
he said that they're irrelevant he said
no he said the Landscaping of games and
the way games are going these games are
going to be less effective two or three
years down the line he wasn't saying
that they were relevant if they weren't
relevant he never would have greenlit
the single player for Halo would have
went just straight for the multiplayer
and if I think that we still need to
work on these games and these games
still need to come out but I do think
that sometimes
these Studios and developers and
Publishers have way too highest
expectations on how these games are
going to sell who who knows maybe if you
would have put days gone as a 40 game it
would have sold better yeah lower entry
I feel like people go in there expecting
their game to to oh you know I think
it's worth 70 dollars but you get games
like Hi-Fi rush out selling 70 games
we're going to see more games like Hi-Fi
rush through added watch
yeah so it is what it is when it comes
to that I I
think they did say they did some slight
layoffs uh they're trying to you know
move people around as much as possible
so people don't lose their jobs and
waves and stuff but it's very
disappointing and it's disappointing
because it's like could have been
huge could have been a big giant game we
could have seen you know characters from
the Apex legends that was really
really built on but instead EA has
decided you know we're just going to
keep funneling more money into into
other stuff and I get it you got to know
where the money is but sometimes I look
at like Marvel and DC Marvel built up a
world
that they could sell little
things of content of Marvel in the
future off of the back of the universe
in the in the past so they took years of
taking else over and over again
so they can get to the point where they
could throw out a TV show that no one
knows about on Disney plus but they know
it's in the Marvel Universe and it and
it has millions of people watching it
and you know people don't like the
sequel stuff and I get it you know my
question to you is do you think do you
think that the way Marvel builds
universes maybe you should have a little
bit more focus and do something like
that in games because I know they're
talking about Insomniac doing that with
Marvel but it's just like it kind of
crazy you know there are sequels but I
don't think
there's usually two three sequels tops
you know sometimes it goes above that
there's exceptions obviously but I think
that building universes is a better way
of doing expansions than consistently
making the same characters in the
universe like for instance you know Sony
could have could have bought Tomb Raider
and they could have made a Tomb Raider
game
and then what they could have done is
cross promote Tomb Raider and uncharger
where they're in the same universe and
you're just slowly building this world
up another thing I would suggest
um Banjo-Kazooie you know if you don't
feel comfortable with bringing just a
badger Kazooie back final way since it's
a make-believe world find a way to to
mix Banjo-Kazooie with Crash Bandicoot
you know do a lot more cross progression
and that way when you start putting
these two games together these three uh
franchises together when you start doing
other stuff and they know it's going to
be part of that centered Universe
they're gonna play it just because they
got to keep up with the uh with the
story currently
[Music]
yeah as long as the initial game is a
huge success yeah I can see that I mean
because we've seen franchises have
spin-offs and nobody cared about the
spin-off you know I remember Shadow the
Hedgehog nobody cares
but I think those are like
out of the universe yeah they're out of
the box thinking they're not okay
they're not building a universe they're
just building an IP in a franchise yeah
like to me like the Tomb Raider you make
a Tomb Raider you make an unchartered
game and then the third game is those
two individual characters coming
together on their own epic adventure
maybe you put a third or fourth one in
there you got um Indiana Jones maybe you
you buy that IP and he's the person
that's that's mentoring them you know
what I'm saying
yeah I see what you're saying um
yeah I don't I don't know it just seems
like with gaming when we compare gaming
to movie which is something I actually
do often also
movies take like
I know the pre-production takes a while
but the movie takes like three months to
film gaming at this point it's just like
years
unless you make smaller games so I do
understand what you're saying but I I
don't know man I it really depends on
the franchise what you know it actually
would work better
and games that were movies because when
you have characters like you know Robert
Downey Jr like I don't want to play Iron
Man anymore
sure you can have voice actors do that
but you could just replace them with
someone that sounds similar not sure is
it gonna be the same performance and you
might notice yes but I do think that
it's easier to continue a universe
that's uninterrupted because sometimes
they have to rewrite these whole story
arcs when these people you know uh God
forbid some of them pass away some of
them don't want to play in the in the
games and the show movies anymore uh
some have conflict of interest so they
have to pull out so they have to rewrite
their story find out what they're doing
with it you know someone like you know
Chad he he passed away playing Black
Panther and that was a huge character
yeah so it wasn't easy for them to
figure out okay we have to write his
character out for the time beam and on
top of that anything he was involved in
in the future we have to find another
way of using him
yeah yeah I mean I see what you're
saying
let's see what you're saying uh
yeah but like I said what franchise
could do that though
there's not a lot but I do think there's
enough that would make sense and even if
you don't combine franchises like Tomb
Raider Uncharted you can start cut
making own spin-off games that you come
out up front from the start that this is
telling a story with all of them
together and not just one
you know we've seen
Nathan Drake through four Adventures you
know if they would have if they would
have started building up another
platform it would have been interesting
to see Nathan Drake with another
personality in there that could have
really went at people you know what I'm
saying
um
so just like a little bit of food for
thought
if that makes sense
yep um you got a member chat
I don't know if you said oh you want me
to read it yeah go and read it for me
real quick if you don't mind donataco
remember for 17 months bask in your
glory while you can dirt when the
Nintendo Direct drops this month and we
get that Zelda gameplay reveal it's a
ride
counting your days come on Donna taco
man
I said brother listen Nintendo they're
they're Legends in this game but um
whenever that Zelda gameplay drop attic
is going to be fully invested in
watching that game play he's not going
to be able to wait
me this is what I'm gonna do with that
that Zelda gameplay drop
yeah I'm joking I'm excited for Zelda
just because I want to play the next
Zelda in the franchise but at the same
time
I was disappointed with a lot of key
aspects that happened in the original
one and that's my mindset it's like
they changed a lot of the core
Foundation of Zelda and I just don't
want them to continue that Trend I I
want to see Zelda the way I feel like
Zelda should be insured
you guys might not see that and some of
you might argue with that mindset but to
me
that's just my opinion
about the matter and guys I sent I sent
it to you on uh on Twitter it
I just want I want the industry to do
well that's why I'm always on Xbox
because when Xbox does better that means
PlayStation can't you know do what we
could talk about real quick is you know
do what they're doing where they're just
canceling the PlayStation collection
stuff or whatever that is for no reason
uh and what's funny is you know Saul
brought up in the in the IOP chat he's
like what's crazy is like a lot of those
games was first party titles that they
didn't have to take out they didn't want
to yeah so it's just like we need that
competition to encourage people to do
stuff we need that competition so we can
get better games in the future we need
that competition so we can get better
opportunities as a consumer in the
future and when I see people say they
want switch to go away or say they want
Xbox to go away or say they want
PlayStation to go away it's like I don't
think you you truly care about that
yep I agree I don't want any of them to
go away like I'm not a fan of Nintendo
but I do not want Nintendo to go away
I do not want PlayStation to go away and
of course I don't want Xbox to go away I
do want Eric the beard to go away though
in the chat oh my gosh
this is coming to hear this talking
trash man
it's Epic
fight going on
laughs
all right so Gaz is here uh he he says
he's feeling a little bit better
uh so let me
fix his his oh damn can you hear me guys
Darth Vader man
what's up hey what's up
all right let me change it again
sometimes like I have to turn it off and
on can you hear me guys I can hear you
okay there we go so what's going on guys
is there a point of the conversation
that really got your attention that you
wanted to come in and talk about I just
didn't want to let you um down man by
saying yes I could do it and then not do
it I was doing the Halo video and every
time I said the line I started coughing
but it started to get better it just
coughed phlegm out a few times I'm here
for you boys I'm here for dirt
let's carry on man I'll jump in whenever
yeah so pretty much what we was talking
is you know uh way uh Titanfall the
single player universe that has gotten
canceled and it kind of like riffled
into a you know
if they're doing like if the mcu's
universe and the way they've built up
those movies to be the Avengers if that
could be done in video games
uh thing is I only a few days ago uh a
couple of days ago yesterday I was just
like they need to make Titanfall three
um it's such a good IP it was so ahead
of its time I think still to this day
it's ahead of its time like Sony the
next big first person shooter is going
to be uh one that plays like Titanfall
because it focuses on traversal
Titanfall 2 did something that a lot of
people didn't expect but they were
asking the TitanFall one which surprised
me which was delivering an incredible
single player game
um I still think Titanfall one was
criminally well overlooked despite it
did well in fact I on four wondered
better than Titanfall 2 despite the fact
that was only on Xbox
and remember when
um I remember I was there at the time
man front front row the console Wars and
Playstation guys were like uh this is
this would sell way better if it was on
the PlayStation but Titanfall too I did
release between Battlefield and the Cod
but yeah it didn't save it
PlayStation didn't save it uh whereas
Xbox and it's marketing at the time I
remember that I was doing interview with
Abby happy that Titanfall got all of
Microsoft's pushed behind it
um first person shooters man
they belong to Xbox man that's the
natural home is the spirit and DNA of it
but the single player going away is bad
I just think they need to do a Titanfall
three
um I'm really kind of sad about that I
didn't like
I don't know man single player you know
the story of BT was amazing like this
was this
Mech robot that had I've cared more
about than most human you know
characters in in stories
um so I was just like
kind of sad when I saw the story on
Reddit that Titanfall 3 you know they're
just completely acts there and we're
seeing we're hearing in the background a
lot of that kind of stuff
so I hope respawn are one of the top
tiered talents out there I don't know
why they've canceled it if it was an EA
mandate that's bad
but maybe it's something internally
respawn thought they couldn't they were
juggling because at one point they were
juggling loads of things they're
juggling Star Wars uh and they'll do a
lot with that and I don't know what the
other projects are but I hope it's not
an EA mandate I hope respawn then
thought you know we can't do this right
or the quality concerns weren't there
that's why we scrapped it and then yeah
Apex Legends probably takes 88 of their
Studio to make yeah really 88 no I said
it probably takes an absurd amount of
their studio to me okay man
yeah this is probably isn't he
overseeing Battlefield now yes yes yeah
yeah now exactly and without Vince I you
know Vin zapella is a Visionary
um he came out from Infinity award and
made this team yeah and he him it was
Vincent Pelham what was the other guy
um zampella and something West I think
they were really this is the importance
of leaders in the in these teams this is
why you know I'm gonna be a dead horse
but Bonnie Ross being gone I'm really
excited now about Halo people will be
surprised but I think that would get the
right leadership in there you can
deliver Madness and respawn if Vincent
Palace is directing his attention to
Battlefield that means and you can quote
me on him the next Battlefield will be
amazing it'll be amazing it's gonna be
amazing
is he the boss yet because where would
EAB the Xbox One PS4 generation if it
wasn't for respawn bro yeah yeah
I think Apex Legends Apex Legends is one
of the only competitors the fortnite
like one of the only true competitors to
fortnite and the fact that you can
realistically call yourself competitor
fortnite and not ever have everyone in
the room laugh means it's a competitor
to fortnite yeah man might not be the
best competitor but it's definitely one
of them yeah yeah it's an incredible
game yeah they Shadow dropped that yeah
that
shocked the hell out of me it's one of
the games I I fell in love with like
mechanically the game is so good like
how did you Shadow drop this like how
did you make this game even day one like
forget the content stuff mechanically
it's so good it's still so good I refuse
to play it now because I'll be addicted
addicted to it that's all I play single
play games now mostly because that game
is so good and that's the vision of that
team if they worked on Halo oh my God I
would jizz myself that would be the
ultimate dream they'd be one of the
students I'd trust with the Haven brand
I I would I would trust them with the
Halo brand I felt like they would do a
lot of unique changes that make sense
like a lot of people say like ID or it I
can't remember who who makes Doom like
the name of the company software yeah
it's software I don't agree with that
one I get the concept behind what people
say uh but I I do feel like Halo and
doom play drastically different and I've
never seen someone really cap doomed for
its multiplayer and to me like if it's
just single player sure but if we're
talking about a studio taking over Halo
as an entity I don't know if they are up
for that
I think a lot of people conflate in
software and put that in the Halo
conversation because of how
um good the engine is because slip space
wasn't turning doing his job originally
just became a meme remember and that's
why people said bring it it scales well
it looks great it has Ray tracing it
runs smoothly so that's why they brought
it in remember it's software
revolutionized multiplayer they
delivered Quake 3 Arena long time ago
long time ago and for since then they've
had they've tried what asymmetrical
multiplayer with
um you know the Doom games they didn't
work quick Champions which I played
great game as old school needs to evolve
there's no guarantee that what Halo
needs
um
for single player it needs I don't know
where this is the big question mark
around there who's the creative director
now uh uh three four three is more of a
technical guy he's got he's under
Stripes as far as I think most Chief
Collection back I think by technically
making it work I think he's he's been
like quoted that he's actually in charge
over there now
I mean we can we can get we can get into
that uh that is a topic uh the next
thing I do want to talk about is this
Undead Labs um I don't know if you guys
saw this but it's actually rumored that
not only are they working on a uh on
State of Decay 2 I mean three but it
does look like there is a good chance
that there are also working on a new IP
or another title and it's supposed to
come out this year so I would assume
this is their passion project unless the
2023 doesn't it oh really oh yeah that's
what I saw I mean let me double check
but that's what I saw the
um
if their passion projects like
they rarely work but they can so yeah
next year 2024 yeah you guys are right
2024.
I want them to deliver the best
um
the best State of Decay and that game
has massive scope massive scope from
what they
if you followed State of Decay from day
one what they they always said they what
they had a vision for what state of
decay should have been and technically
whatever the old crap Jack called CPUs
held them back couldn't really deliver
it with State of Decay 3 is what they
really want to do just take everything
they built you know the Community Focus
with this massive multiplayer online
world and it's just like Walking Dead on
speed
um I really want them to work on that
but at the same time if they want to
work and have a passion project they can
work pentimen worked like it's not they
may not be the kind of game we play but
critically massive success the five
dollars from Carver um space has issues
but it's a good engine Destiny's tiger
range is a fork of the Halo blaming just
like slice uh slip Space Engineers you
know that that's kind of unique unique
way of thinking about it actually like
the tiger engine and the slip space
engine all came from the concept of the
same engine
yeah I mean the slip space engine I will
say
the the way it feels felt right and
there's a big question mark around
whether Unreal Engine will replicate
that feeling
um of the Halo feel I also like whilst
that visually was in terms of raw visual
Fidelity it was pretty yeah but the art
style was great
it's a bit of a shame that you did all
that work in r d and then obviously
forsaken it which means the engine
wasn't good enough to work on it works
because they've worked hard to make it
work but because they relied on
contractors they had to get used to the
engine it just didn't work practically
yeah I think it you know logistically it
probably would have cost them more money
to revision and re-uh optimize that
engine the way they needed it to uh
because I think that engine was probably
built under different parameters on how
they wanted Halo to function and then by
the time they realized how they wanted
Halo to function the engine was already
built and those type of steps are not
cheap to go and restructure
yeah and let me say this
um when it comes to slip space like yeah
I said the game felt great Halo infinite
in my opinion um it's still a solid game
clearly the slip space engine
um the the team at 343 clearly they're
not a fan of the engine they're not able
to
it seems like the engine is giving them
issues if it wasn't they wouldn't be
switching engines right
um so if that was what was stumping the
team uh if the engine was the problem
with them getting out more content
if they could see issues in the future
potentially with the is with the engine
amen they have to do what they have to
do um so I mean but people been wanting
them to kind of reboot they wanted them
to change some things around
and it's happening so uh I'm all for if
if the team thinks this is going to
better hey though
do what you got to do yeah I mean you
know going back to the undead Labs uh
scenario you know the question I have to
you guys is you know see something like
obsidian I think we can all agree in the
general Community to agree that they
have earned the right for a passion
project
um you know you look at someone like uh
um Hi-Fi Rush sure maybe even within was
in everyone's cup of tea but it was
still a good game to a lot of people and
I think that might have but with all the
issues that stated Decay had coming out
the door and all the hiccups that it had
and it took a long time for that game to
fully get where it needs to be uh do you
think there's some studios that would
have would you consider would have to
earn the right to have a second team
working on something or do you think
it's like look like you know the last
game was kind of like choppy you need a
you need to show me a little bit some
some before I trust you on a second
project
I gotta say it's my quick gas before you
go I think Xbox
um some of the like one of the reasons a
lot of these teams sign with Xboxes
because Xbox gave them carb launch they
say yo you guys can do what you want to
do
um we know that Ninja Theory they you
know if we watch that video when they
first sign with Xbox there you wasn't
really looking to get acquired but they
talked to Microsoft Michael said listen
you guys can make what you want to make
with our resources
cool you know bleeding ass didn't really
turn out great for them but they were
still able to make they're making some
games that that they want to make
so I think if XBox you know if like I
don't know State Decay or on their lab
say yo Xbox we want to make a passion
project as well as State of Decay three
I think that would be wrong for Xbox to
say hell no you can't make a passive
project it's focused on state of the K3
um if if their pitch was yo we like you
guys can do what you want to do with our
resources so if that was the case and I
believe that was the case because we
heard Xbox did a lot of Studios you know
listen man you guys can do what you want
to do we're not going to make you do a
certain type of game
[Music]
Yeah man so if they're comfortable
they're doing state of the K3 and also
doing something else I think that's fine
yeah so when you said yeah I agree with
you Doug um when the way you frame the
addict is like
have they earned the right I do I would
never say you are now allowed to work on
your passion project because
I know what you're saying I know in the
terms I was saying it's like look like
you know you got something wise like
yeah Is it wise to do like compulsion
not compulsion Coalition you know uh it
seems like all everyone else getting to
work on passion projects but like 343
Coalition even though how we feel about
three four three and how they dropped
the ball multiple times can you look at
that studio why everyone else is going
to get getting to go out to eat multiple
times a week and say you eating chicken
noodle soup like salad
no it's a tricky it's a trick this is
the tricky part of managing
um you sometimes have to make the
difficult calls and it's a balance
between saying you have cop lunch to do
everything
and I think this is a bit of what Matt
booty was doing they swallowed up so
many studios they struggled
sorry
and they expanded way too fast and they
sounded really fast in a short space of
time so a lot of the problems we see
with Xbox were inevitable and ABK will
add to that weight I keep saying it
that's a ABK in the studios you know
Activision Blizzard they are a mess
internally they are a mess you're not
telling at Microsoft to fix that problem
Activision and blizzard fans
are true Activision Blizzard fans are
actually grateful because Mike or
hopeful or grateful if Microsoft buy
them because Microsoft can fix them
get rid of the leadership fix that up
but that's not going to be easy it's
going to be hard Microsoft has already
shown that kids struggle
um but the lessons it's learning now are
great timing for when ABK does go
through which it will go through but in
some delayed period of time but it will
go through as we found out today meta
just slapped the FDC which was always
going to happen in my opinion you cannot
stop a big business but that's a
different conversation but in terms of
balancing you need a strong personality
that says all right like three four
three come up to uh imagine I'm the
leader I'm Matt booty and 343 come up to
me and say hey look we got this side
project we really want to work on and
you're like right you've just taken on
Halo and we need to know what you're
doing you're working on under an engine
you need to give us deliverables and an
appreciable timeline and you can
convince us because they'll be stupid
for us to give you cop launch in light
of everything that's happened right now
we would say stick to Halo because
you've got a lot more to chew on if
three for three came up with a side
project it would be stupid unless the
side project on paper had such
tremendous value or uh you think promise
and those are leadership calls Sony does
it all the time sometimes they'll select
some things slip and that's the risk you
have to take but sometimes you have to
have the balls to lead and uh to lead
and say okay and with Xbox it's obvious
some studios and Publishers are better
poised already to deliver obsidian
they've already shown it double fine you
know they're really well run they've
delivered a great game let's see what
they do next you have more confidence in
obsidian than you have in say Undead
Labs but you know we heard about Undead
labs they were like having internal
issues as well within Studios and their
own developers said they were
disappointed at how hands off Microsoft
were and helping them when they had
issues with leadership there are clear
examples there not every rule the rule
cannot apply to every Studio it's a
dynamic every Studio have to take on its
own Merit so we'll see
um I it's just it's a very tough job
whoever at Microsoft because you know
can you imagine if it's like you you're
uh like guilty if you don't do anything
but someone someone will break the news
and say well Microsoft is too
controlling oh here we go it's like you
know how do you balance that
so it's always going to be difficult hey
guys oh I'm sorry addict let me say this
right away real quick perfect example
when Buzzy wanted to do Halo I'm sorry
destiny
Microsoft said hell no you want to
continue to do Halo so Buzzy said okay
we're going to do Halo Reach and we're
out of here yep so there's so like
that's that line you said now
do we want to get those guys Freedom or
do we want to make them so there's a
balance that needs to be there right you
know exactly I think doing uh you know
like a smaller game or doing some type
of passion project will kind of help the
morale of the studio if you know what I
mean so if they desperately want it and
it feels like it so look we really want
to make this work and you think all
right we'll we also believe in your
vision we'll let you do it but you have
to make a convincing case we're not a
charity that's what Microsoft should be
saying like we have finite number of
sources yeah we're Microsoft explain to
us show us say we're Xbox not Microsoft
we got a budget Microsoft might not have
any budget but we have a budget I just
think to me
I want everyone to have passion projects
but I I see the redrick on Twitter I see
people saying you know why is this
studio going to do one the studio does
it first off we don't know what these
studios are working on for all we know
343 and Coalition are both working on a
passion project we don't know uh but at
the same time I can understand where
people are coming from where it's like
you know some of these Studios have
dropped the ball in some way shape or
form and it's like maybe you should uh
you know prove to the consumer base
prove to The Gamers prove to Microsoft
and Xbox that you know you could ship
one game that hits the notes that you
thrive to hit before you start unlocking
the doors to more funding for multiple
games so it's like it's like I said uh
that you end up getting to Logistics on
are you gonna lose talent because
something that is so simple to let them
do where you need stuff anyway are you
gonna lose talent because of that and
sometimes it's easier to give a studio a
little bit more budget to make that
smaller title than it is to potentially
lose the best talent that's there and
then you're back at score one
yeah definitely
and yeah look you have to
it's a balancing act and we'll see we'll
see I feel like Xbox and its management
is getting better
and angle game works is helps with that
narrative because they killed it yeah
nowhere yeah and I'm not going to say
too much uh we're about to get into the
Microsoft thing you know let's let's
just go there now because I know guys
always got bars for Halo uh so all right
so we seven minutes there you go
timestamp police uh you know don't come
after me
so all right guys let's let's talk about
like like super chats if you want to get
them before we get them yeah let me get
those real quick
we got ten dollars trip with your baby
father
um
uh Microsoft game studios is a great
track record with passion projects
grounded pinnamon and now high five Rush
as long as Studios have their a team on
a main game I welcome these I agree I
agree with that too but it's like I said
I do understand where people are coming
from they're like look some of these
Studios have improved they can make you
know that their their main game out the
hill so you know maybe you should let
them you know fine-tune those issues
before they make another game uh you got
another five dollar Super Chat from uh
baby father uh can't work on patching
products if you're already having a hard
time on what's already on your plate so
yeah only certain Studios should be able
to it's like I said you know
it's like gas that's a hard thing to
maneuver around especially
20 plus Studios you know you got 20 plus
uh head heads that you gotta maneuver
around you got teams within teams you
got heads within teams within teams like
Nightmare Man nightmare but let's eight
minutes man we we talked about that for
a minute so eight minutes and 40 seconds
dude we talking about Halo infinite you
know let me read this little update from
Jason tryer now I'm gonna let you guys
talk mainly about this because I don't
want to catch myself out of tone here uh
but Microsoft's 343 industry still had
uh we'll still make Halo games despite
rumors uh to the contrary but the mass
layoffs at least 95 people uh an engine
pivot to Unreal and then Focus only on
multiplayer for the near future 343 is
hitting the reset button new story uh so
it looks like they're going to pretty
much re relaunch Halo Story Probably
Rebrand it in some way shape or form who
knows how how they do that but I'm going
to go to you guys because I feel like
this is something that you've been very
vocal about you know a lot of the
management issues that's happened over
there and you know I will say this what
you guys hear it's worse but you know
continue and I I want to know your
opinion when you see that you know
maybe some of these layoffs and maybe
some of these people leaving I will say
there has been some people I've seen
leave 343 that I know has been issues
like part of the management issues so I
will say that there is Max there's
drastic restructuring going on there but
what do you feel guys
uh I'm looking at a video on this now I
know I think pretty much
most people apart from like idiots from
the PlayStation side who don't know
about me kept saying oh you didn't call
out Halo I'm like bro you know you're
talking about
um I've been scaling off management uh
people had to go at me for celebrating
when Bonnie Roth was uh set down but I
think she was let go
um and not in a bad way but
the to me it's a
it's a good thing because
I find I was what I I'm shocked it's not
me trying to Pat myself on the back but
I will say like I was right but one
question I kept asking and no one was
asking and my review said this my review
said the community will
want an aggressive road map for the
single player content and my review is
written there and it's like the success
of this game is predicated on an
aggressive uh content roadmap for the
single player
and then nothing happened nothing
happened and now from Jason sharia's
article in Bloomberg they didn't even
have a road map they were working on
passion projects toying around stuff
with Unreal Engine for the story
and that I didn't know it was that bad
that was really bad that means you
didn't even believe in your own 10-year
vision and you had contractors out there
it's it's management problem because
you had all these incredibly talented
people but management didn't actually
commit to a vision and
I was going to say what I will say
is
the way I see it and the way I've Been
Told
people are right with the management a
lot of people like to try to blame this
on overall now it is Phil in in
mattoon's Fault to to advice yeah to a
degree because they are over those
Studios but there there's a couple
people at 343 that you know they're so
weak to blame for the stuff that's going
on it was it's like a domino effect you
know when yeah when you go into this and
you know the way it was described to me
there's a lot of
I don't know what to do with this you
know there was a lot of work that was
done that was just thrown out there was
a lot of wasted stuff that happened for
343 and I I feel like when it comes to
this
at this point
the fact that the people who made the
slip space engine they're up out of
there the fact that Bonnie Ross is up
out of there the fact they have a lot of
the pr people that's been migrated to
other people the fact that they're you
know potentially might Outsource the
single player I know the 343 came out
and said that they weren't doing that I
don't believe them I think that's PR
speak I think they'd rather show you
good content before they ask for
permission to have someone else make the
Halo game uh so it's just like I I I
have
I'm at this point with Halo and 343
it's like
at this point I don't even want to see
you don't come out to play don't put
anything in the window don't put that
thing on the inside other side of the
door where this is do not disturb
because you don't have to do that I
assure you we're not coming in we don't
care what you're doing you know once you
lose the The Gamers what's what's a good
word a gamer's perspective in our not
even our will like once you lose the
the
man I just had it and what's don't you
guys hate when that happens yeah
it was good but once you lose that
aspect and you know the the good will
I'll say that too it's just it's almost
impossible to get it back and no words
is getting that back they come out there
they could say they can have like that
I'm grateful for Christmas 25 day thing
and it can literally instead of being
why you're grateful for Christmas it
could be apologizing to the Halo
Community for 25 days and we're gonna
say that's cute let me see something I
don't care like
yeah you know absolutely I I mean
the
it's the expectation for me for 343 in
Halo was always high because I believe
that's the station it should inhabit
it's a flagship title it represents Xbox
and if this game that visually was
lackluster became a joke content wise
failed and all this management happens
you've got to feel a certain way
especially if you have a high
expectations for Halo and I still
believe Halo can
School everyone because there's so much
scope in Halo there's so much scope in
Halo
it's just just real quick guys someone
said halo infinite was 87 Metacritic you
guys are acting like they released a 60.
um it was an 87 on launch but they
released it and I used the words games
as a service Seasons multiple times
people expected content that's the
problem here
if if the 87 meta argument I don't know
who said that in chat but if you're uh
argument Stood Still we wouldn't be
discussing this right now there wouldn't
be Mass layoffs right now there wouldn't
be a management shift you wouldn't have
x three four three members are saying
the management and Leadership were wrong
you literally had the senior multiplayer
director saying Halo should be in a
better place than it is now I'd blame
the leadership I'm sorry
that's pretty sure the saying that
Pierre Shaw literally in your face
you've got every argument has crumbled
away and yet you're still defending what
I believe is mediocrity in light of what
Halo should have been a 10-year plan you
sold us a 10-year plan you ditched that
plaque didn't have a road map for that
it's bad stop excusing failure when the
failure is staring at you in the face
it's there it's admitted it's done Xbox
have said it Phil Spencer said it Phil
Spencer in that interview with IGN what
did he say about Halo he said we fell
short on what content and what's the
word quality
quality he said quality he said quality
twice because they know it they know it
if you're a Halo fan what do you want
Halo should be the best looking game the
best playing game the best supported
game it's a fighter for a reason exactly
it made Xbox it embarrassed everyone all
these Halo killers that came out killed
this just died they had no chance and
Halo could still do it but when Halo
infinite comes out with less features
than its old games including the first
ever one what do you say and we still
get made excuses and I still believe if
you look at my reviews very glowing but
I did say needs more can't ill you sold
us this games as a service you said
Halos goes to be free to play show us
guys
what's that it's like Halo is like back
in the day Halo was this giant thing of
armor it was impossible it was
impenetrable no one could do it but
there is this dagger and the only thing
that could penetrate their armor was
their own weapon and then they
consistently would try to stab someone
but instead of attacking that game like
they supposed to the Halo killers that
would accidentally go too much and stab
their own self in the chest and after
enough of those stabs Halo was is
limping man they're not moving like they
used to they didn't and you know what uh
addict all this happens for a reason I
believe this is going to make Halo
better there now piance is here and I
don't know his credentials other than we
fixed the Master Chief Collection which
is a technical feat which is great it's
not the way I've been described about
that individual is the studios behind
him not the eye rubs the actual people
working on Halo and that's so important
because that wasn't the case before and
now I'm excited and I have questions
regarding unreal engine's suitability
for Halo but if they believe in it fine
but you know what with Unreal Engine at
least I know the game is gonna look sick
it's gonna look nice yeah because Halo
infinite even by its own demo of the
slip space engine didn't look that gray
I'm this is this is it now
they know they have this last chance and
that's what makes me excited I just hope
they have some creative uh Vision there
the creatives you know but new
leadership people rally behind what you
just said addictive the whole team is
behind Pierre and all the leadership
then I'm I'm J if I was jaded I would
tell you at this point no one can doubt
that I would not I'm not hiding my
feelings if I thought this is bad news I
would say it but I am genuinely excited
bad news is we don't get uh
sample Master Chief story for a few
years
and the sad part real quick is the
atriox character had so much potential
man from Halo Wars to to building up for
the Halo infinite and now it seems like
they about to be like a true Ox who
exactly yeah
sorry I talked for a while sorry
um okay so the way I feel
um I feel that this was most likely
pretty necessary uh because you know
things was happening like the thing that
was telling to me
was the person that said um I mean well
like in the whole thing that Jason
schreier said that there were team
members that was saying yo let's move to
Unreal or or or they were coming up with
concepts for a different ninja it just
seems like the engine
these guys didn't like the engine the
engine slip space was the issue
okay we've moved past that part and I
just want to say this
clearly there were some issues with the
engine the leadership clearly there were
some issues at this point
all I can do as a fan of Halo as a fan
of Master Chief as a fan of Xbox
is like addicts here okay we uh Pierre
hints this is is his time to shine we
needed some changes people wanted
changes right so like the thing that get
me when people say we want changes
but when the unfortunate part about
changes when people lose their jobs
people like what
this is unfair no no that no that's that
comes with changes right um
they're making changes needed changes
that people have been asking for I love
Halo infinite I thought the game
released pretty polished but it was
missing a lot of things we know what it
was missing um and afterwards it was
missing the like the content was coming
out rather slow
so all I can say is that this is what
people wanted
Pierre Hans is running the studio
they're making some changes they're
changing engines and we'll see what
happens after this that's all I can say
yeah I mean you have to be positive oh
you don't have to be positive you can be
skeptical but I think this is I mean how
many more changes like you mentioned uh
they've changed leadership they're
changing engines I mean I've never now
they're rebooting though there there
seems to be rebooting changing
everything like I mean it's like like
you watch sports you know I'm a big NBA
guy you can trade a player here you can
trade a player there you can get a new
head coach but I've seen teams that
completely shut it down and built built
it from the ground up and sometimes
unfortunately it takes some years to get
things back to where you want it but it
was necessary you had to have new faces
in in the in the management spot so
yeah
my thing with with this is you know let
me read this member chat I've been
screaming from this from the rooftop
Story one uh member trap from slo-mo
backslaps have have machine games make a
new Halo focusing on the story campaign
combining that campaign with the
multiplayer amazing 10 47 games uh
makers of split uh split gate I I
stopped that though daddy
yo yo yo give this studio Halo okay uh
machine is doing Indiana Jones and and
hopefully they'll do another Wolfenstein
so what it is was it stop making their
game you know what that means though
they gonna be making Wolfenstein Indiana
Jones and the Halo single player mode
but then we just had a conversation
about teams doing too much that's fine
Wolfenstein could go down a little bit
you know I don't even like that game I'm
perfectly okay wolf is not inspired me
but I like the atmosphere Wolfenstein
gets but I've never really been into
like the the story of like uh you know
uh the Nazi stuff I've never really been
into stuff like that but uh I never
liked the way they played mechanically
oh I can I understand other people like
it yeah the yeah I just didn't like it
it just felt too floaty for me I tried
it um and I was Colt told me to play and
I just like couldn't get into it but if
other Studios have a Halo's lore is so
vast if resources and bless you if
there's other Studios wanna do that then
maybe let them explore but I also like
the fact that 343 have said no well or
the new 343 we want to retain control of
Halo that means they they believe in it
they want to control it and Xbox believe
in their Vision so I said fine go for it
go for it I get it wait a lot of people
say that though
like for me it's more about those other
teams are doing their own things like if
there's a brand new team that want to
come in and make a Halo game that has
some great veteran developers that's one
thing but just oh yeah let's give it to
them so compulsion what what happened
what happens if they're like okay we'll
take some of the leads from machine
games some of the leaders
and we'll let them work with three four
that's something different yeah that's
different like like taking some guys
from a machine or taking some guys from
it or whatever that's that's different
but just to give it to the whole team a
lot no three four three
no you can why can't you give look Halo
cannot be told tell multiple stories
people do like agent lock but what
happened to Blue Team what happened to
look at his team what happened nothing
completely dead there's so much law in
Halo I agree with that tell a bet a
story of Halo before Master Chief was
even on the face of the Halo Planet like
pre I've talked about this precursors
story is amazing if someone has a vision
for it hard sci-fi that kind of vibe
give it to a studio that wants to do it
if they want to do it three four three
oversee it and they will play that
overseeing role let them do it if that's
the case if not I'm not against the idea
but right now I think 343 are going to
be focused on delivering the the what
what did Phil Spencer say that they've
building up a plan and they've got a
plan for it now and
they've already bought the IP rights for
Halo the endless
remember Halo 4 story is massively
disconnected to Halo 5 which is
massively disconnected to Halo infinite
Halo 4 you had the whole Greg bear was
commissioned to you know Greg bear rest
in peace he passed off passed away last
year incredible sci-fi author who
delivered three great books and it's not
a small feat just and
they built this law they delivered
incredible story in my opinion Halo 4. a
really good story but it didn't didn't
connect to Halo 5 which we know the
story about and then Halo 5 didn't
connect to Halo infinite because they
took a shortcut and they rushed it now
they yeah hints and his team at 343 will
need to reconcile the the broken
storytelling and deliver something great
they I think are committed uh to the
Halo endless thing because that would be
really weird I I cannot see them
forsaking the endless now they will
still commit to the endless I I still
think they'll commit to Zeta Halo the
story Will Carry On from there
um there's too much there too much law
you've shown offensive bias in the end
of the trailer you've you've built the
hype up for it that's fine
so they'll carry on like that it will
Carry On from there but let's see what
that's my it would be crazy for them not
to do that if they re recap completely
redid it that would be shocking to me
it'll it'll carry on with the Halo
endless and I think that will be the
next title will be named ill they've
already got the IP it will Carry On from
there so let's see what they do I am
positive uh I've got a video coming out
on it explaining why I'm excited about
Unreal Engine have some concerns about
the feel latency well not latency the
zorko was talking about latency with me
but um just feel of of Halo but if they
can smash it I'm sure they can uh
depends on the team but this team is
going to feel the pressure more than
anyone and that's the kind of
environment I like because they're gonna
give it their all NPA has proven it with
Master Chief Collection he fixed the
crap out of something that people
thought was almost impossible to fix
that's a technical fee let's see where
they go I am generally optimistic just
means it's going to take some time let's
see by then God knows if I'm alive by
the time they've released this sequel
but so what was you gonna say don't
well just one last thing before you read
the super Jazz
um what I'm trying to say with giving
Halo to another Studio
what I'm trying to say is if that other
Studio
is doing their thing
um I don't want
any resources taken from another game
like people say go with the ear software
I'm pretty sure it is making the game
right now uh give it to
Coalition give it to machine they're all
making games
now if you're going to this like I said
if there's a studio that happened not to
be doing anything right now or something
if you want to take some people from
uh that studio that's fine but I just
don't like just to give it to them okay
perfect example I remember Tomb Raider
right shadow of the Tomb Raider came out
Crystal Dynamics couldn't do it because
they were doing Avengers
so they gave it the items Montreal but
the thing was Otto's Montreal wasn't
doing anything hey yo you guys do this
while but we oversee it while you know
while we're making Avengers we're
overseeing now if that's the case that's
one thing but
if yo uh we'll pause Doom like the next
doom and do a Halo I don't want that I
want those games now if the team is big
enough they can break it into pieces
that's fine but I just don't like this
give it to know I think three four three
needs to fix it I feel you and I do I
always tell people
Halo is a brand of single player and
multiplayer one of the few that it
actually matters to a lot of people
absolutely and it's not going to be easy
to replace that now if you split them
and have one person do that in three
four three work on the multiplayer
that's one thing that might be doable uh
but you know the way that they always
talk about three uh about making Halo
infinite multiplayer I don't
realistically think you could have did
that why simultaneously making single
player you know you look at you know
look at Epic with fortnite a lot of
respawn works on uh you know Apex
Legends
these massive games as a service Bungie
all making Destiny they take the
majority of the studio and when you when
you you could see when Studios start
letting the gas off you see it with
Destiny now because they're making that
other project matter game so it takes
the majority of a studio to make these
type of games and I think you know
splitting the studio up in that many
that might be one of the issues but you
know was you gonna say something guys
I was gonna say slo-mo's point isn't
just love uh he he's like don't put
words in my mouth but I kind of get what
he's saying in that if machine games
have an appetite for it they pitch it to
343 and Xbox hey by the way we could
deliver a good side piece story on Halo
verse like odsd type something would you
why not would you guys be okay if you
know other Studios instead of making the
core Halo Studio let me make a spin-off
let me make a third one I'd be okay with
that absolutely
but who would not want to walk on Halo
though let's be realistic who would not
want to work on Halo see this is where
the good leadership comes in now because
you need to make an assessment here are
these the studio whoever the studios
comes up to you and say are they chasing
the money because they know they got
pretty much Surefire hit here or let me
assess okay what's your vision what do
you want to do a side piece on what show
us what do you intend to do and that's a
leadership call and if you don't and
then you have to balance it with three
four three and Pierre what you don't
want to do is like hey Pierre we've
talked the thing it appears like why do
you talk to them about this so Pierre
needs to be in those conversations day
one he seems to be on the in the or
sitting there at the table with them Mr
PA look machine games have come out to
us and said they want to deliver they've
got a really good idea for I don't know
Forerunner Saga story
um maybe you could work that in with
your game because we know your story is
focusing on say for instance bringing
back men
um
The Didact because they're actually two
dot eggs uh but
um okay let's have a this is this is a
leadership challenge here involve Pierre
now trust in him as well machine game
sit down and say we have a good vision
for it convince us great Side Story
enhances the universe the biggest
problem with Halo is this lore is so
good the games don't do it justice when
they made the TV show which I haven't
seen it because they're bastardizes
everything Halo with Master cheeks show
Halo's face having sexual Cortana what
the hell is this [__] man and then you
see the stupid Last of Us and Pony's
clapping for the last of us because the
wanking off this is doing well and I'm
frustrated I'm like I want Halo to be
that game that series because I know it
can crap on Star Wars it's that good
um but if you can tell stories like that
that would be great
um so yeah like it depends it depends on
the Lucy's just bear with me gents
what's it
all right so uh you know I I feel you I
I feel you I think I think at this point
we're just gonna have to see
we're gonna have to see a lot of uh you
know pushback when it comes to Halo
that's why I'm always that's why I'm at
this point where I'm like just don't
talk just going to hiding don't say
nothing until something's ready to be
shown and I guess that's where I'm
personally at right now but let's talk
about this massive stuff that happened
real quick so our last topic uh you know
34 minutes for the timestamp mafia
dirt
yeah dirt it looks like the last Nails
might have been putting the coffin to E3
man looks like it might be done yeah
this done destroyed it was it wasn't
killed it was butchered or however they
put it man however they put it so what
what'd you think about that dirt when
you saw that man do you first off do you
think it's true and second off you know
what what do you think this means for E3
if all the big players don't show up
well first off to ask her the second
question if the victory is not there now
we know Sony pulled out a few years ago
um Nintendo they might have available
what they call them tree house or
something there Xbox was the one that
was still around
um so it was slowly dying anyway and
then Kobe hit and it was officially done
but then we got kind of hype last yo E3
is coming back in person shows oh yeah
yeah hello
but the thing is
if Xbox is going to have their own show
Nintendo has their own show they have
directs throughout the year PlayStation
has a state of plays
they're probably going to have a
showcase this year you know now Xbox
have these Xbox developer directs it's
like at the point with today's
technology where you see the Video Game
Awards their numbers and
it's almost like they don't need E3
anymore like you know it's unfortunate
now me as a guy that I used to love E3
used to I still watch some of these old
e3s I just watching them bro just love
them
um
this is a different time so I'm not
gonna say it hurts me because they're
still going to have shows just not at E3
um XBox seems still seems to be doing
their show during that E3 week or maybe
before the E3 week
so it really doesn't matter at this
point yes I used to love the week of
gaming news I used to love it you know
it was on Spike TV here in the states I
used to love it G4 I mean G4 but now
it's kind of like okay
they don't have to do it that way
anymore you know these companies got
their their own strategy and as long as
they have shows Xbox has confirmed Phil
Spencer himself confirmed that they
already know what they're going to show
this year
as long as they continue to have shows
I'm fine but E3
it's gone man
yeah so uh what What's your thought all
night let me get these two projects real
quick guys got a 108 uh fight out super
shot from 108 Dragon TV shout out to the
awesome panel guys addict but I have to
say dirt is the realest Xbox supporter
he's even glowing green on camera Super
Saiyan dirt oh damn yeah
[Music]
what's up addict Dirk and guys you see
the new uh atomic heart Gameplay trailer
today looking above and beyond looks
good I thought it's gonna be like they
keep showing vertical slices I think you
know they're selling games that look
like you remember what's that other game
um early on bright memory infinite and
it was like oh it looked really good did
that game come out no one said nothing
hold on let me tell you let me say this
the demo was terrible right yeah but
when they actually dropped the game I
bought it it was actually pretty good
man I'm gonna try that I haven't tried
the full game yeah it was so much better
than it's really short it's like three
hours long okay but I'm telling you the
demo I was I was like damn this is
actually pretty good because like I said
I know what the demo was terrible but
that's what game is actually pretty good
it was only it's only about three hours
long I think it's only like 20 or
something it's actually pretty good okay
I might try that
dead planets could Starfield have
planets that reference other games that
would be cool I would probably they
they're they're famous for that so I
would definitely see that so guys man
you know uh tell me tell me what your
thoughts on E3 what's going on guys
when when I go there
and I can still stroke your beard that's
all good you you're there it makes no
difference to us other than maybe a gang
like what's the difference Microsoft is
still there on the Sunday we're still
gonna get apparently that Nintendo is
going to be there too so but they
they're just not going to be on the
actual show floor
exactly and it's just like okay it kind
of just shows that the attention is
is moving to these directs look at the
Xbox uh Bethesda developer direct was
really good and you know that kind of
signals that you know there's big events
on the place to be you can control the
narrative you don't have to worry about
tactical positioning you know Microsoft
was always first Sony came second and
they could do loads of things including
by the start of a console Generation
price changes last minute they'll have
parameters big problems there now
they've taken control back
E3 it's sad it's sad the big one the big
news is Microsoft is not going to be
there but it's still there on the Sunday
event so as long as that kind of stuff
is there because I think it'd be really
kind of I've never been to E3 but the
hype for me being there to meet you guys
that is the thing that makes and just
seeing people in person get hyped about
it to lose that
kind of sad and I don't want to lose
that Bloody lemon bought like a two
thousand dollar camera lens for E3 man
like let the guy make some videos
I think yeah
finish what you're saying guys yeah no
so yeah it remains to be seen but I
think you know as long as the shows take
place around that event because that's
like our Christmas for us if that
doesn't go away then uh that I'm happy
but it does sound like like you say the
death of e3 as we used to know it yeah
man yes oh man you remember some of
those memories
yeah man come on Mark come on Mark
Malkin come on show us some damn respect
sir dirt race racing officer Mark malcol
with the five dirt race racing better
than terms
come on man
okay
I think this is concerned hey come on
guys I'm gonna laugh with that man
what'd you mean bro you were looking at
me that make you fun of me on your show
I'm cracking up I'm to be honest I find
it funny as well but
so first off we got 285 people in the
chat man hit that like button I know I
know you guys are sitting there I know
it's hard to hit that like but I know
it's so far away from the screen I know
especially if you're on your phone you
know that that just tap I know that's
hard to do might break your thumb don't
sue me for for any types of medical
bills man I ain't paying them you know
uh having a hard time turning on my heat
what makes you still gonna pay your
thumb bill but you know E3
ah I do feel like this is concerning a
little bit now
it's the first year back out of the
pandemic really
so there's a good chance that this is
going to happen regardless if it was uh
the esa because the esa are working
together with the people who make packs
to bring this up here now so I'm hoping
that E3 still going to be around and
what one way shape or form it depends
how the year does you know and as much
as I I respect Jeff Keeley I don't like
his event I just don't like the summer
game show like I want all I want my
appetite in three or four days all right
I don't want my appetite in three months
it just it takes two ever
now the content creation Part of Me
loves the three months because it gives
me content for three months out of the
year right yeah but the gamer in me is
like nah that ain't it that ain't it
give me my stuff now I ain't waiting I
want remember that that year we had to
wait till like the end of July for for
the E3
yeah yeah we had to wait to the end of
July that sucked like that really we're
used to having that that nice little
stake in June and we had to wait till
July sure it's a month and it was at the
end of July but it was it felt forever
yeah a lot of people don't realize when
it comes to E3
Sony hasn't been to E3 in years but
they're upstairs in meetings
they're still there they're just not
paying money to do to do business there
they're just still using uh renting out
you know stuff upstairs running out
rooms they're still doing their uh
business transactions like a lot of
people just see what's on the outskirts
they don't see what actually goes on in
those those those rooms upstairs like
the good thing about E3
and you know especially Gamescom you
know these big big shows especially E3
and Gamescom more E3 because it's a lot
of the north uh North America uh content
creators and there's a lot of them is
that's one of the few times a year where
you can easily do business because a lot
of people are in the same area and I
don't think people realize
as long as that exists and as long as
it's easier to just set up a showing
with 10 to 15 influencers or streamers
or media than it is to fly all 10 15 of
those out to your establishment to show
them there
people are going to do what they can to
keep this alive sure this year they
might not be there but what what I will
say is my influencer friends and my
streamer friends you better apply this
year because I'ma tell you even if you
even if you don't go
you better apply man okay give that nice
I can't go email because once you show
that you got approved once it's a lot
easier to get approved again and let's
say you go want to go next year Xbox
comes back they are able to work
relationships to get Nintendo and Xbox
back maybe even PlayStation
then we're going to be talking different
now I don't know if that will ever
happen but I wouldn't be surprised that
they're able to you know get that
communication back to get them people
back on the show floor and it's it's
disappointing man because this is one of
the first times where I've seen where E3
might not make it and you know it's like
I said it's like our Christmas man for
years yeah every year I'm looking
forward to E3 every year that that that
that may month goes by so slow because I
know E3 is right around the corner oh my
God I started taking days off
like I started taking you know when Xbox
change their days to Sunday obviously I
don't have to take that day off but I
was taking Mondays and Tuesdays off bro
because I had to sit back now this
before I was doing content I always had
to sit back same watch the shows man
I I hardly take annual leave I actually
had like 21 days I had to carry over for
this year
um but the only days I took off was for
those shows
so sad but yeah with Gamers bro that's I
mean that's what we love to do and uh
man so you know Adam I am going to miss
uh the E3 because like I said I watched
are you coming often uh probably not no
come on man you should try to make it
this morning
fast
they've already paid the money they
can't cancel at this point I would think
well I got a a big Disneyland trip
Disney World trip this year so I was
like yeah ah definitely not fair enough
fair enough they're basically what Vegas
too so it's kind of like yeah
I'm hoping with some luck
um because we're going to PAX East in
March I think it's in March I'm hoping
starfield's gonna be there I'm hoping by
then
that probably will be I know redfall
most likely be there but I'm hoping
Starfield will be there yeah Red Bull
definitely be there yeah
e3s man I miss uh man it's gonna be
disappointing if it goes it really is
like I know a lot of people ain't really
cared since
since um Sony left it but it's like you
don't care but you watch every
conference so you care it's just you're
mad because Sony's not there yeah
well yeah ain't no attic as a bot I
gotta be honest it hasn't been the same
since Sony left it hasn't yeah it hasn't
been you need all three to play it's
true like once one of the pieces we're
still Gamers at the end of the day and
the competition is also really good it's
always good to see who did better and as
well like the fun of that so yeah it
does it does suck and the plus you look
at the standpoint just strictly it's
like it's for your fans man like even
though Nintendo wasn't there as a press
conference for all those years they made
sure to show up in an actual floor like
they sh they were there for their fans
one year it was literally I think it was
it was a breath of the wild I remember
it might have been Mario Odyssey I can't
remember it might have been Odyssey but
yeah it was Odyssey literally when you
walked in the entire they rented half of
that half of that place
and it was all one game damn it could
easily say we're not going we only got
one game but like no our fans are going
to this and we're gonna show up
and I got to respect them for that man I
got to because you know Sony and Xbox to
some degree in some ways sometimes you
know they're like yo we don't got we
ain't showing up like last year
PlayStation didn't even have really
their own little console okay and you
know at it I hey bro I'm like to say
that because you know what I actually
respect
during those years 2017 2018 2019 when
Xbox literally didn't have any damn
thing in development besides Halo gears
and force they still was able to I was
just about to say that yeah three even
though
uh 2017 E3 was okay 2018 83 was great
2019 83 was in but they still were able
to have some put on they put on E3 shows
for us right now I would say that's
that's great you know uh yeah because
back then like I always say on my
channel in 2017 bro not only did they
not have games they didn't have a road
map you know so now they have a road map
but they always put on a show that's why
it never makes sense to me when you
could criticize I don't mind criticism
like I love when people criticize Xbox
but I don't understand how you go off
like jump out the ship you know what I'm
saying like you mean to tell me you made
Xbox content through the dark ages of
Xbox but the moment stuff starts to even
look slightly going downhill he was like
it's time to go
this is what people thought I was doing
because I got but like crap Gamers
Legacy I'm like why does it have to be
like him like I I've always broke don't
people say there's a crap game reverse
curse or something like that like
everybody exactly now he's back on Xbox
like
you can change your mind but it's like
it's obvious when you do it for clout or
it's obvious when you do it for views
I'm not going to say too much about him
uh or people like him in this space but
it's just like yeah I get it tastes
Dynamic whatever but I fought for Xbox
during the bad days the worst generation
I was in n4g fighting like a I was the
most hated Xbox
on that website moderate has told me
they would get like 30 DMS a day 30 DMS
a day about me
um and
that's the thing with Xbox fans Xbox
fans we are used to this is why I like
Xbox we'll feel like we were on the
journey with Xbox I know it's kind of
crazy because Microsoft is a trillion
dollar company but the Xbox division is
crafted by its fans it's by its mistakes
and by striving and there's something
about an underdog that does that so to
Dutch Point yeah you're right like when
they didn't have anything they still
tried so and they really did TR and Phil
Spencer does care about celebrating
gaming with fans in person no one does
it like Microsoft does they invite they
fly people out or not fly people out but
how old events then Colts being there
other people being their influencers go
there they meet up you guys iron Lords
you guys going to all kind of Black Tie
events or New York game show you guys
looking slick sitting there meeting Todd
Howard meeting Phil Spencer Hey that
that wasn't me I wasn't there yeah you
weren't there which is sad but like
other other Lords were there like that
is really important uh it may it it
makes a big difference to the community
so we get rid of events like E3 you kind
of get rid of that connection with
influences with Gamers with everything
we're the same like we're just everyone
in chat it's the only difference is
we've got cameras we're talking about
the games absolutely these events are
important
because for smaller content creators too
like if you can get the numbers to go to
these events yeah you have a lot more
access to some of these people and now
imagine taking these events away
you know since you're there Studios have
no problem working with you you're
already there they might as well give
you free content so they can get free
publicity but if they weren't there and
you weren't there do you think do you
think Microsoft 2K EA Ubisoft flying
these small con to create hours content
creators out to look at their games no
no they're like hit me when you get
taller hit me when you get taller like
yeah exactly exactly yeah yeah yeah hey
hey black you guys said I I am one of
the guys in the chat you know everybody
know my story that listens to my channel
I I am one of the guys in the chat and
I think why um there's so many Xbox guys
that's
like some people say like I remember
slow-mo said they're sensitive and I I
don't like to say that
because we all have different
sensitivity levels but what I would say
is
why some Xbox guys is mad at gas or some
other Xbox channels
um some of those guys some of us I would
say we like these Xbox channels to get
away
from the PlayStation Fanboys that's
everywhere right so we go to our
favorite Xbox Channel and you know
you guys are like what
yeah yeah then you know you might have
you know some ponies on your shoulder oh
come on man no so
what I like to have it like but you get
to know the people they're actually
sound people and if you're sat down
would have dinner with them some of them
are crazy I get it some are crazy some
people I will not ever chill with like
woolly gamer there's no way that's gonna
be a fisticuffs someone's getting a
criminal record
that's gonna happen guys let me tell you
exactly I don't know if you know my
story but I talk about all the time I
was there where you are right now yeah
and I was yeah yeah we're all adults I
can be cool with these guys I was cool
with some of them and then I started to
notice that they would still throw me
now it was we're talking trash in the DM
yeah yeah it would throw me up on the
bus on Twitter throw me up on the bus
doing this damn it man like I thought we
were supposed to be cool right you know
then all of a sudden
it hit me like I don't know these guys
for real I don't really have to be
friends with these guys and and it just
like like I said because I'm a uh
and I know how the guys in the chat
thing like yeah I feel you man and what
happened was there was some other stuff
that went on behind us I could tell you
behind the scenes uh guys with some
other ponies I was trying to be cool
with and I said whoa
and then I realized if if your internet
Persona is a POS I don't want to know
the real you that's just me because I
don't have to know you I I don't know
your real name I don't know what you
look like it's like I don't have to
force oh relationship with a with a dude
you know what's crazy and I might learn
that lesson I might you know you're
right there so I might I'm I'm like that
my Mantra is uh if you walk towards me
I'll run towards you'd like to give a
chance I don't want to be a prick to
everyone and I just like to be nice but
it's happened to me loads of times but
people will take advantage and watch
this space it might happen and you've
been burnt by it it might happen to me
and then you will say guys I told you
and I won't have anything to say because
I was like
I tried to give people chances and I
feel like I tried to do it too but you
know yeah it might bite me in the back
back side who knows that's why I always
keep thrash he deserves to get mucked
and yeah I saw the stuff he was doing
yeah I did yeah I like that I shared it
it's just like me and Colt and everyone
were talking about like what is wrong
listen man we talked about it afterwards
but yeah yeah we'll talk about it
seriously sorry sorry this is yours
sorry about that attic but you know one
thing I could say people say what they
want you know when it comes to
personalities on the internet
people say what they want about BG but
you know what I always see in the chat
he blocked me with daughter talk who
said besides BG I don't really trust the
other ones like I I like BG he's always
having conversation he will come on the
show he will have a chat no matter who
even if he's blocked like him and Jade
up had issues right I wanted him and
Jade up in there uh not jdub hey J Rock
him and Jay Rock had issues but Jason J
Rock said I'm cool with him if he comes
on and BJ say I'm cool with them and
like internet beef it spills out quick
everyone knows look I'm team Xbox this
guy's playing Team PlayStation you'll
have beef it happens all the time but
I'm trying to remind myself like we're
older now like it's still video games
it's not a problem I like BG I like I
love weapon wheel podcasts I love the
balance
yeah I don't know what happened but I
don't even interact with them
I don't know why I don't know see this
is the thing that everyone's like and
now you're I'm worried like having
people message me like why you like it
I'm like you know he blocked me I'm like
bro I I came in this space two years ago
Brian like I was fighting in the
trenches on the front lines on n4g now
you guys are on Twitter I don't know the
history behind all of this but BG is a
cool guy I don't know what was going on
with that and it's just but I never and
I want a show where I have Xbox and
ponies fight each other and I'm just
having fun time because then we just
thrash out and they realize it's just
jokes whether that's possible or not I
don't know but it's just personalities
man but the main thing is are people
being sincere are being real uh that's
the real question people being fake then
that's the real question right there
yeah that's the one if they're being
fake of doing it for clout then then
that's fine anyone dares say that to me
that pisses me off so if ponies come out
and they'll weaponize that I will
obliterate them and their whole family
how dare they say that to me that is not
something I will stand for to say that
I'm not real that I will not stand there
I can almost guarantee the reason you
got blocked from BG
is because sometimes BG be getting
really emotional on certain subjects and
he'd be just dropping band nukes
everywhere I don't talk to him bro no it
would be like one of those things where
like you know how like when you comments
yeah you know how like sometimes you'll
call it all threads that's commented on
threads and you don't realize the
originated of the thread was like
someone else yeah you probably commented
on one of those the BG just got rid of
that whole threat it's cool man it's
cool because I was on no like this was a
couple years ago I think it's before
Kobe I was on weapon wheel like four
straight weeks
um then he asked me come on one time I
said I couldn't you never asked me again
I mean it's cool I don't want to go in
there anymore anyway but um yeah no
matter what
um I don't know I'm learning in this
space I'm just learning this I'm gonna
hit a BG we about to get to the bottom
of that bro yeah it's an attic it truly
does not matter
at the same time at the same time if
it's something simple I would I would
like its results
that's cool I I see I wouldn't call BG a
pony though like yes
he was one of the few PlayStation guys I
actually like because I always thought
he was fair
buddy I feel you all right we'll figure
it out man we'll figure it out but you
know appreciate everyone for coming
through you know we we had a good uh
massive amount of people in here tell
the people where you at man you know
what it is uh swamp the the chat with
your with your links uh make sure they
know where you came from yeah he already
had it yeah
oh what happened I don't know
um yeah guys check out my channel uh of
course it's a pro Xbox Channel
um it you know I gotta be honest it's a
pony free zone
it's a pony free zone because I'm so
tired of those guys it's like that guy
that came in early Erica beer he had
jumped in my chat one day saying ah
we need to save Haven away from him
um
so you're getting rid of me too his chat
will get rid of you oh yeah his child is
ferocious bro
they think I'm a pony That's How Strong
they are but I love I love your show I
always do that that's it guys this uh
sub you know I do regular videos got a
podcast on Monday evenings WBZ Xbox
podcast we have a lot of fun we talk a
lot of trash and that's it guys
they're great so definitely check it out
yeah so we'll get gas man what where can
people find you when's this Halo video
dropping oh man my voice is getting
better so hopefully tomorrow
um and everyone's like oh here you go
guys crying about the Halo again it's a
positive video because I feel positive
about the features tomorrow I can check
out game on daily one word
um check that out and Saturday we have
go live uh chat show
um but yeah check it out uh yeah
hopefully I'll do well by you with this
video it's gonna take a while to edit
I'm not sleeping today I'm not sleeping
and you guys can catch me uh Lord
addicts IOP uh so someone uh put gaz's
Link in the chat
thank you
yeah so uh
go Packers that's exactly why you
blocked on my channel you punk man
you're lucky I ain't on my channel
[Laughter]
I could be talking about church yeah
I love when Dirk just goes at someone in
the chat he's like he's like just come
over here come over here and say that to
my face
you know like my chat blocked him a long
time ago shut up
I don't rock with these ponies man like
this is years of pent-up frustration bro
like like TJ um said earlier in the chat
you know I always say they beat my legs
in black generation and it was pretty
bad
you know I I kind of uh like Envy these
new Xbox people showing up that haven't
dealt with this nonsense Right Next
Generation
they have no clue how real things was
last year there is times where it I you
know I wasn't making content like I make
now but I couldn't imagine what it was
like making content back then like oh my
God I was doing podcasting but I wasn't
making individual videos and I couldn't
imagine what it's like to like back
before the studios are being bought to
like come up with videos to be made
during that time it's like yo we're
talking about the five Studios that Xbox
owns what's Minecraft oh my God
bro not only that I started my time I
told you this before but I started my
channel right after they cancel scale
bound they uh got rid of fable ledgers
and lion head they had no games I was
green right so I didn't know what was
going on I didn't know whose friend who
was foe I was not doing console war
stuff at all
that's how somebody said dirt was bully
I wasn't bullied but I didn't really
know how to fight back I had a hundred
Subs right opponents are still coming
into my chat attacking me and I had 138
Subs right I didn't know how to deal
with it I went on a couple podcasts and
those guys quitting on me they turned to
ponies it's like what's going what's
going on so yeah there's a reason I am
like I am and remember the the Xbox cont
the Xbox people Civil War
[Laughter]
people don't realize the stuff that was
going on behind closed doors
there was a time where there was
literally a civil war going on between
Xbox content creators it might as well
have been uh the uh what What's the
Civil War on on on The Avengers like I
yeah evolved okay I wasn't if I was in
my own little corner I was like at the
top like you know with some binoculars
watching what's going on but what caused
that what was it I can't pull it I can't
remember exactly what caused it but it
was it was bad for a while man it was
bad for a while coach you might can ask
Colt he might remember it yeah let me
ask him
um because yeah he's been covering it
for a while I I regret it so much I
didn't even know Twitter uh had this own
thing I had a Twitter account made years
ago did not be used to it uh so I was
just like man like I don't know how to
use this I was sitting in the trenches
n4g is a Pony Paradise song oh my God
yes it was so bad and I was there me and
two of my other friends were just there
battling it out it was just a constant
gangbang I'm sorry anyway but yeah the
xBox wasn't giving us ammo gas
five dollars super trap from let's play
with each other's joysticks
I miss guys at least I got to see his
face before the show was over I'd like a
caught with him one day oh
guys and dirt